[Music]
from not Amy Schumer thank God comes
another Greta gorwig film about a pretty
white girl's quarter life crisis but
this time it's the backdrop to a literal
toy commercial
Barbie
welcome to Barbie land a place where
everyone lives by Nietzsche's doctrine
of Eternal recurrence this is the best
day ever you guys ever think about dying
I mean a pretty pink neighborhood where
everything is perfect unlike the toy
aisle it's a land where every race and
body type of Barbie is treated equally
as they all copy how they're being
played with in the real world minus the
times we make them kiss and match their
smooth plastic Mounds together I do not
have a
never stop me Margot Robbie shines as
stereotypical Barbie the best pairing of
actor and toy since Vin Diesel stuck his
hand up a street shark
you'll believe every step of our
emotional Journey except the one time
she doesn't feel pretty Margot Robbie is
the wrong person to cast if you want to
make this point in the first film since
Legally Blonde or someone pink and girly
wasn't a villain because the villain
role is already taken by man I mean can
Ryan Gosling finally gets to shake off
his sleepy-eyed murder face and take his
back to his Disney door Crews
give me that pie
in a comedic performance that transcends
funny for someone who looks like Ryan
Gosling
that's fine and approaches funny for
someone who doesn't look like Ryan
Gosling I have apologies I hope the nice
guys was a fluke but no there's really
nothing left for us how goes game over
Gus wins
[Music]
follow along on Barbie and Ken's trip to
the real world sometimes it's the
reality we live in sometimes it's more
zany than Barbie land
there Ken will speed run through the
manosphere like a middle schooler's
first Andrew Tate video
what was that well Barbie will have to
balance handling her new feelings of
inferiority with the superior handling
of the new Chevy Blazer EV
[Music]
IL I gotta lose these chuckleheads
[Applause]
her discomfort with being judged by her
exterior with the smooth comfort of the
new Chevy suburban's interior thanks for
the ride this has been so much fun my
truck car I'd like to have actually in
this epic Voyage of self-discovery that
wouldn't be possible without first
getting into the 1956 Chevy Corvette C1
it's subtle like a rock
but Barbie and Ken aren't the only
characters getting in and out of various
Chevrolets there's Gloria who's
show-stopping Mama log Builds on the
ideas first set forth by a hand with
pobodies nerfect on it not only are you
doing everything wrong but also
everything is your fault her daughter
Sasha a life-like Bratz doll who shows
young girls how capitalism subsumes all
critiques into itself you represent
everything wrong with her culture Barbie
Landing saving Barbie needs saving weird
Barbie who's so weird you don't know if
she's gonna do the splits or reinforce
China's territorial claims over Vietnam
Alan Michael Sarah's long overdue
apology for the crimes of Scott Pilgrim
Will Ferrell as Lord Business the CEO of
Mattel whatever and a rousing game of
spot the actor from every British TV
show Greta Gerwig likes
because we all stupid now it's up to a
Barbie movie to teach audiences about
feminism oh look the Supreme Court
they're so smart the patriarchy I'm a
man with no power does that make me a
woman and female anatomy I'm here to see
my gynecologist in a fresh new
installment of woke Wars 2K 23 that did
the opposite of go broke in a basic 101
level lecture full of broad
generalizations and naive fixes we're
giving voice to the cognitive dissonance
required to be a woman under the
patriarchy you robbed it of its power
yes because it's a popcorn movie
congrats you're smarter than a child's
doll here's a student loan so enjoy the
Smash Hit of the year that shines thanks
to its incredible production design
perfect casting and a release date that
got them more Free Press than the
Grimace Shake in one of those hits that
should remind Hollywood women like good
comedy too but Warner Brothers will see
the results and conclude toys they love
looking at toys give me Uno give me
Barney give me my Magic 8-Ball what toys
starring
the Pink Ranger Goss and the Real Girl
brand Parenthood when is Gamora Allen
Barbie mama drama you're just a woman
woman with a small brain the brain the
third the size of us it's just science
Cynthia from Rugrats reps
Chong chard C-sections and Barbie land
are a bit excessive Aqua every couple's
costume this Halloween every tick tock
this year
when you know they had Tarantino
[Music]
when you know they lost Tarantino I
don't want to touch a foot when they
stuck it to film Bros it's like I've
been in a dream where I was somehow
really invested in the Zack Snyder cut
of Justice League and when they went too
far oh my God you've never seen The
Godfather can you start the movie over
and just talk through the whole thing
The Godfather is a masterpiece Francis
Ford Coppola's Mastery of The Craft is
Bianca oh no I'm one of them aren't I
Guys and Dolls
[Music]
I have a TV in my back you know whose
dream that is nobody nobody's dream did
they not consult any men on the script
we crunched the numbers on the age
dynamics of every movie romance in an
all-new episode of by the Numbers
spoiler alert keep James Bond 500 yards
away from a school at all times click
the box in the right to learn why
I'm a Barbie girl in the Barbie world
life in plastic it's fantastic you can
brush my hair undress me everywhere
imagination right is your creation Come
on Barbie let's go party